that's a really good question okay so
first of all for many years when you as
a diplomat thought about muslims or
islam at the State Department it was
Middle East centric so you always
thought about one region of the world as
as Muslim there are more Muslims that
live outside of the Middle East than in
it that's the first point how do you
understand what's happening with those
communities around the world all things
Muslim are not the same you have to
understand the texture and the nuances
because that is the only way as a
diplomat that you can begin to think
about the changes that needed to take
place you're not giving dignity to
somebody if you say oh you're Muslim
this is what you mean you all you all
look the same you all have the same
brand of Islam you are all the same that
is so disrespectful in so many ways I've
traveled a lot because I don't want to
only just go to one part of the world to
say you're the most important you're
talking about strategic interests
Copenhagen the how much do you know
about what's happening in Denmark with
with Muslims or also or Stockholm or
London or Madrid or Milan or Vienna
unbelievable shifts in paradigm is
taking place on the ground because of
several things that are taking place in
Europe you have right-wing movements
that are taking place not just about
Muslims you have generations of second
and third and fourth generations who
that are Muslims that are born in Europe
that are feeling isolated from the norm
you're seeing an increase in disparity
in terms of jobs in the workplace for
people who have qualifications you're
seeing an increase of a misunderstanding
of what it means to be Muslim among a
generation that will only go to one part
of the world to say if I'm Muslim I must
be this very problematic al Qaeda would
like you to believe that all things
Muslim are this that's their whole
that's their bread and butter right then
and there right if you are Muslim you've
got to believe this you can't have any
views other than your else Islam is
really diverse there are 1.6 billion
people on the planet that don't have all
had the same opinion on various things
there are different types of Islam as an
American foreign policy objective we
want to pay dignity across the world not
just a Sunni
it's not just a shia not justice Meili
is not just a Sufi is not we are looking
broadly and what it means to be Muslim
and respectfully in terms of what it
means to be Muslim the growing trends in
Western Europe 30 million Muslims in
Western Europe alone that trend is
growing how they impact the culture and
the society and the politics is going to
make a difference to our national
security as we understand the trends of
radicalization that's happening with
affiliated groups from al-qaeda and
what's happening in Europe that's making
a difference to our foreign policy you
saw the news last week with London and
Paris and Berlin you also see
underscoring all of this a growing
division I'll talk very specifically
about the Nordic countries between
genders the men in these countries who
are Muslim are not getting very well
educated the women on the other hand are
moving up the lines they're pushing
really hard what is going to happen
think about sociologically what it will
happen to these these groups what women
in the Nordic countries are telling me
is who are we going to marry if we want
to marry within our faith we're doctors
were lawyers we're school teachers were
professors these are men who are
uneducated I could go on for a long time
about the issues that are taking place
in Europe it is a very important part of
our national security it is a critical
part of our national security not just
because of the of the terrorist threat
but about how it changes the fabric of
what it means to be European what the
issues are they come to bear for the
first time in history the United Kingdom
has a Muslim as part of their cabinet
fire baroness warsi how are the changing
faces of Europeans thinking about
various foreign policy issues they
affect our bottom line so Cairo Egypt
sorry Egypt is very important to us I'm
not saying it's not but to say that all
things Muslim must be driven by a either
the Middle East peace process or driven
by issues that are very specific like
water or various other things that are
happening in that part of the world is
really problematic we have to be honest
about what the things are that are
taking place across the world